alors là mais le rejet est un champignon
lignivore donc qui consomment du bois
qui absorbe le boa qui le qui le rend va
dire vulnérables et qui provoque une
pourriture cubique
alors ouais même dire dans une maison
quel est l'impact si on n'a pas de bois
est bien le problème de la mais lui sait
qu elle se décompose en deux éléments
majeurs
le mycélium d'une part le sport au fort
donc la partie reproductrices le fruit
si on peut s'exprimer ainsi qui est
l'oncle organes reproducteurs qui va
produire est dispensé disperser les
sports ce fameux mycélium a deux
inconvénients dans le bâtiment il va
d'une part détruire le bois est fait une
pourriture cubique donc le bois devient
inutilisable
cassan fragile et cetera mais elle
produit ce qu'on appelle des tuyaux
qu'on va appeler des sirops tu sais si
rod sont donc des cordons mis ces liens
qui vont d'emblée dès que le
développement de la melde est avéré
aller chercher de l'humidité et ses
fameux sirop de ce fameux mycélium à la
capacité d'incruster les maçonneries
notamment par les joints et donc eh bien
on va se retrouver avec une maison
gangréné un petit peu comme un cancer on
va voir ce médium qui va être un petit
peu partout dans les murs
pourquoi la dame et russes de plus en
plus tout simplement que personne
n'ignore le réchauffement climatique
donc un peu plus de chaleur un peu plus
d'humidité des conditions donc météo qui
change qui évolue d'un autre côté on a
accès en france sur l'isolation de nos
maisons sur la perte de calories à
l'appart calorifique
donc on isole nos maisons de plus en
plus peut-être peut-être maladroitement
par l'extérieur ce qui fait que l'on
regarde effectivement les calories mais
on regarde également l'humidité
or l'humidité avec le bois fait mauvais
ménage puisque dès qu'on a dit militer
avec du bois dans une maison on a un
développement de moisissures de
champignons lignivores et donc de mérule
et puis après naturellement ça va
s'accélérer
plus on admire hull plus on a de sport
de méru
qui sont diffusées dans l'atmosphère
faut savoir que 10 centimètres carrés
d'un sport fort de mérule va envoyer
dans l'atmosphère 4 à 5 milliards de
sport et donc on a le cercle infernal
qui fait qu'on a une prolifération